scary movies allow us to confront our
fears from the safety of the couch
but some of them hit a truly terrifying
nerve
we're here to dig deep into the ones
that stand head and shoulders above the
rest
spoilers ahead lori strode is a typical
teenager who spends her time babysitting
when she's not in school
then the deadly michael myers breaks out
of his institution and burns laurie's
normal life to the ground
john carpenter's halloween provides a
masterclass in suspense
as myers weaves his way in and out of
lori's orbit
slowly shredding her sanity when the
horrifying and prolonged showdown that
ends the film arrives
it's with a sickening inevitability
still it somehow manages to thrill and
surprise
more than four decades after the film's
release michael myers is unique among
slasher villains in that he remains
inexplicable
we never really gained any insight into
why he is the way he
is well at least not in this movie
even the first sequel offers little in
the way of understanding
this makes myers uniquely frightening
there is no secret memory
explanation or phrase that might disable
him or even just render him more
comprehensible
he is terror personified and that gives
viewers plenty of fear
you know it's halloween i guess
everyone's entitled one good scare
stanley kubrick's cinematic adaptation
of stephen king's novel the shining
might not be the most faithful
adaptation of the book but it is one of
the scariest films of all time
set in the remote overlook hotel during
the height of a winter the isolation of
the setting is terrifying on its own
but when you throw malignant ghosts
tidal waves of blood and a madman with
an axe into the mix
well the stakes don't get much higher
than that the shining is a world of
terrifying imagery
strange behavior and family drama that
builds to one of the most unforgettable
climaxes in horror history
here's johnny the fact that it's unclear
whether the ghosts are real or figments
of the torrance family's imagination
only adds to the unsettling nature of
this truly chilling masterpiece
the tagline for ridley scott's
nightmarish alien
is in space no one can hear you scream
and this classic film certainly delivers
on that creepy premise
the crew of the nostromo find out way
too late that a distress signal from an
unknown planet
is actually a warning to stay away by
that point
a crew member has already been attacked
by a mysterious alien creature whose
implanted egg bursts from him in a
famously gruesome scene
things only get worse when the crew
overrides ripley's command
and breaks quarantine procedures which
leads to the alien creature wreaking
havoc on the ship
visually masterminded by artist h.r
giger alien is simultaneously terrifying
and gorgeous
the chess burster scene is as harrowing
now
as it was decades ago while ripley's
confrontation with the creature is
equal parts exhilarating and horrifying
alien
is a suspenseful strange and exciting
journey into a deeply terrifying space
gerald's game was once considered
stephen king's most unfilmable novel
however director mike flanagan's 2017
adaptation beat the odds
and delivered a classic horror film that
has multiple levels of fear
going on at the same time after
attempting to spice up their marriage
jessie's husband gerald dies from a
heart attack while she's handcuffed to a
bed
in a remote cottage the front door is
open allowing a wild dog to get in and
begin eating gerald's corpse
things go from bad to worse as jesse
relives childhood abuse
and begins to suffer the effects of
dehydration then
a monstrous man begins visiting her at
night one who may or may not be a
hallucination
gerald's game hits hard and fast with
moments of emotional agony
shocking gore and sickening cruelty in
the hands of its capable director
it all works together to create a truly
disturbing work of horror
while jessie survives her ordeal no
viewer will ever forget how
it's one thing to be isolated in
antarctica it's another thing entirely
to be isolated along with a
shape-shifting alien entity that wants
to destroy you and every other living
creature
i don't know what the hell's in there
but it's weird and pissed off whatever
it is
it's worse still when said alien turns
out to be capable of mimicking humans
perfectly
making it impossible to know who to
trust chronicling the horrific
experiences of helicopter pilot mccready
and his crew
john carpenter's the thing is a work of
uniquely potent psychological horror the
creature itself is a grotesque amalgam
of all kinds of creepiness
from arachnids to disembodied human
parts but what might be scarier than the
monster
is the way the humans turn on each other
in an instant their senses of trust and
community are casualties of the monster
right alongside their lives the thing's
ambiguous ending
only adds to the terror inherent in this
classic story
neil marshall's claustrophobic
masterwork the descent has a terrifying
premise
a group of best friends get trapped in
an undiscovered cave system with no
apparent way out
that alone warrants inclusion on a list
of scary movies but the horror increases
exponentially when the women discover
they're trapped with a horde of
cannibalistic monsters who have
evolved to live underground our heroines
are forced to become their most primal
selves in order to survive
the version of the movie that aired in
the uk has a far
bleaker ending than the one eventually
released in america the women never
actually make it out of the cave sarah
hallucinates escaping
only for the closing shot to reveal just
how deep down she is
and how slim her chances of escape truly
are especially given the monsters are
closing in on her
the conjuring spawned an entire universe
of movies
some much better than others so it's
easy to forget how
bone-chillingly scary the first
installment is
featuring paranormal investigators ed
and lorraine warren
as they help a family with a possible
poltergeist the conjuring masterfully
balances short-term scares with slow
burn narrative energy
only a movie at the top of its game
could weave together possessed dolls
secret passages and centuries-old curses
into a coherent and terrifying ending
director james wan draws some
extraordinary performances from the
film's child actors who do so well
they improve everything around them
you'd think kids in peril might be a
well-worn horror trope but the conjuring
reminds you why it's a cliche in the
first place kids make horror visceral
the child killing ghosts working her
dark magic from well beyond the grave
is all the more terrifying for menacing
these particular kids
the conjuring is a triumph of modern
horror that should definitely be
applauded
both the original japanese horror film
simply titled ring
and its american remake the ring are top
contenders for scariest movie of
all time while the original may be more
understated when it comes to imagery and
production
the ring doesn't ever feel over the top
there are two variations on a great
story
both of which will scare you beyond your
limits both films follow a haunted
videotape
after watching the tape viewers receive
a mysterious phone call and then they
die
seven days later if that's not a spooky
enough premise for you
the story of the demonic ghost girl who
haunts the tape is the stuff of
nightmares all by itself the moment that
samara crawls through the television has
become iconic for good reason
it's a shocking defiance of the natural
order of things
which is basically horror in a nutshell
we all know the twist in m night
shyamalan's the sixth sense by now
yet decades after its release the little
boy at the center of the story
continues to give viewers a good scare
they scare me too sometimes young cole
is brought to child psychologist malcolm
crow
for help in handling what appears to be
delusions cole claims he sees and hears
dead people
nobody believes him at first not even
crow but as time goes on
the truth of cole's gift becomes clear
and so does the truth about crow
the sixth sense's ominous tone perfectly
placed jump scares and clever staging
keep it tense
while it's strong performances make it a
story worth watching again
and again though it's often considered a
thriller rather than a horror movie
it doesn't skimp on darkness one subplot
memorably features a stepmother
poisoning her new children for attention
the sixth sense is a story about the
murky complexities of the human heart
and the way they linger
even after death in jennifer kent's the
babadook the monster seems to be a
figure from a mysterious children's book
found by samuel a young boy being
brought up by his widowed mother emilia
but the actual villain of the babadook
is grief amelia and samuel's pain at the
tragic and unexpected loss of their
husband and father
has curdled into something utterly
devastating
something they need to face head-on
before it destroys them both
amelia and samuel are driven to the edge
of madness by their bereavement to the
point that amelia attempts to strangle
her own son
when their salvation arrives it's
surprisingly gentle
and all the more heart-wrenching for it
from its story to its performances
the babadook is as powerful as it is
scary
the story of a wealthy and
well-connected family who begin to
suspect their son is the antichrist
the omen features one of the scariest
children ever put to screen
damien thorne is a strange boy to whom
strange things happen
for example a mysterious rottweiler
shows up to protect him
then there's the creepy nanny who takes
her job as damian's caretaker far too
seriously
i have no fear little one
[Music]
i am here to protect thee the plot
thickens dramatically when damien's
father robert discovers that his real
child was killed and switched with
damian who was birthed by an
actual jackal the omen's haunting film
score tremendous performances
and strong script add up to a harrowing
journey into evil
one that still manages to shock even
today the final scene of the film where
damien smiles during his parents funeral
remains profoundly unsettling
in the 1992 film candyman daniel
robitaille
is tortured mutilated and killed for the
crime of falling in love with a white
woman
he returns from the dead as the ghostly
killer candyman
with a hook jammed into the raw flesh of
his wrist his terrifying presence is
invoked by looking in the mirror and
saying candyman
five times then it's only a matter of
time before some unfortunate soul hears
his signature phrase
be my victim
daniel robitaj's tragic backstory
remains a relevant indictment of
american racism
while tony todd's commanding performance
as the killer forms the rock solid
foundation that the rest of the movie
builds upon
candyman is one of the most complicated
slasher movies around weaving a web of
violence
history sorrow and rage it's a pained
frustrated howl of a movie as cathartic
and sorrowful as it is genuinely
entertaining
like home invasion stories tales of
demonic possession are a uniquely
terrifying sub-genre of horror
both explore the breach of a person's
physical and spiritual autonomy by
malignant outside forces
no film encapsulates this horror more
potently than the
exorcist young reagan's possession by a
demon is viscerally horrible
the entity absolutely trashes her body
with sadistic glee
the exorcism itself is equally grotesque
possession is a bloody brutal business
in this film
and all the more frightening for it but
the exorcist is also a terrifying look
into medicine's long history of
disbelieving women and children
ellen burstin's performance as reagan's
struggling single mom chris
grounds this movie in firm reality in
this regard she is helpless to save her
child as she begins cursing and spewing
bowel at anyone within striking distance
the horror might be fantastical but the
experience is
all too real in the 1981 film an
american werewolf in london
taurus jack and david are given two
pieces of advice by yorkshire locals
stay on the road keep clear of the moors
of course the two don't follow these
basic instructions as a result
jack gets mauled to death by a
mysterious creature and david gets badly
scratched
david begins to suspect something is
seriously amiss when he starts having
horrific nightmares
and then he wakes up in the wolf
enclosure of the london zoo
david's first transformation into a
werewolf remains one of the most painful
and terrifying scenes in movie history
jack's appearances as an ever
deteriorating corpse
are just as horrifying to say nothing of
david's slaughtering multiple innocent
brits
add in some astonishing special effects
work and brilliant moments of black
humor and you've got one of the scariest
backpacking stories ever told
featuring demonic clown dolls a
skeleton-filled swimming pool
and sentient trees poltergeist set the
bar high for stories of supernatural
horror
the freeling family is perfectly normal
and happily ensconced within their home
in a planned california community
unfortunately everything falls apart
when their youngest child carol anne
begins acting
very strange
when the girl is pulled through a
mysterious portal the situation only
gets worse
the entire community as it turns out is
built on a graveyard
developers only move the headstones now
the dead are out to assert themselves
as if that's not bad enough the film
itself was plagued with tragedy
both during filming and after plus
remember that horrific pool scene
the production team used actual human
bones from a medical supply
company because they were cheaper than
making props
when the blair witch project first came
out the film was marketed as a true
story which made watching it a truly
harrowing experience
today most viewers know it's not
actually real but the creepiness
persists regardless
watching heather mike and josh lose
themselves in the maryland woods
on the hunt for the blair witch remains
a long and terrifying journey into dread
as the hunters become the hunted heather
reflects on the various mistakes they
made which got them into this awful
predicament
this scene has been parodied to death
and yet it retains its power
heather's desperation is undeniable
making blair witch equal parts sad
and scary plus the ending never fails to
shock as it leaves so much to the
imagination
we never fully learn what actually
happened to the three documentarians
but we can certainly imagine and that
makes it worse
dario argento's moody classic suspiria
is as much an art house movie as it is a
gory descent into the supernatural
suzy banyan is new to her fancy german
dance school but it's not long before
she notices the school has a body count
as suzy uncovers the demonic coven of
witches at the heart of her academy
things go from bad to worse in
increasingly bizarre ways
scored by celebrated prague rock band
goblin the creepy music that wallpaper's
suspiria
adds to susie's mounting dread grotesque
imagery abounds
once you see a woman trapped in a huge
ball of barbed wire
you won't soon forget it add in
argento's close-up camera work
along with the film's vibrant use of
color and you've got a symphony of
horror
sight and sound harmonized to take the
viewer to new heights of fear in
suspiria
one marvels at its beauty even at its
most shocking
being stalked by a serial killer is bad
enough but being stalked by one who
kills people through their dreams is
next level scary
wes craven's a nightmare on elm street
minds that simple premise
brilliantly with an iconic and
terrifying lead character
before he existed in dreams freddy
krueger was a mortal man who preyed on
children
eventually he was killed by a group of
locals when his activities came to light
after they burned him up they vowed
never to speak of him again
years go by in which kruger's spirit
devises the ultimate revenge
he will torment the children of the
people who set him ablaze
although some of these parents are in
denial about his return
but he can't get you now
he's dead honey because mommy killed him
the use of dreams makes nightmare a
movie
still capable of invoking actual
nightmares their lack of logic throws
all the normal rules of horror out the
window
what do you do when the only way to
avoid your monster not sleeping
is physically impossible freddy krueger
is a movie villain unlike any other
and that's what makes this film a spine
tingling classic
in get out photographer chris and his
girlfriend rose have traveled to her
family's estate in upstate new york
chris thinks he is rose's first black
boyfriend but he's dreadfully wrong
the armitage family are actually
murderous racists who transplant the
brains of aging white people
into the bodies of the young healthy
black people they kidnap
the armitage's perfect country home
their manly demeanor
and even their liberal politics are the
cornerstone of director jordan peele's
scathing critique of race in america
but even after chris manages to escape
their clutches
he is confronted with the flashing
lights of a police car
audiences hold their breath wondering if
chris will ever make it home alive
this haunting inn makes get out one of
the scariest movies ever
in a devastating exploration of systemic
bigotry
david fincher's crime horror film 7
follows detectives mills and somerset
during somerset's last week of work the
partners are investigating a serial
killer who is using the seven deadly
sins as his guidebook
fincher's chili aesthetic understates
the horror of each homicide
which actually makes them scarier a
world in which these grotesque deaths
are treated as normal
is a frightening prospect most of the
violence takes place
off-screen which is both blessing and
curse this is a movie that wants viewers
imaginations to go wild
to fill in the blanks and to leave them
with some serious questions
what's in the box seven's ending is also
one of the bleakest of all time
and one of the most unique in being
caught the killer wins
the villain's plan is a master stroke of
horror as is the movie that features him
jaws may be a classic but it has nothing
on the authentic terror of chris
kintus's open water
hardworking couple daniel and susan go
on a tropical vacation to reconnect but
end up getting left behind in the ocean
after their scuba leader miscounts the
people on board the ship
the couple spends hours out in the sea
it's not long before the sharks begin
circling and the two feel their strength
begin to wane
if this premise doesn't scare you on its
own consider this
it's based on a true story watching
daniel and susan struggle to survive as
the sharks get bolder and they grow more
dehydrated is terrifying enough
but to know that two people actually
went through this
that's another level of horror entirely
the ending is as
chilling and hopeless as it is quiet
which makes it unforgettably tragic
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one